no minister this morning what do you
think of that
well i think it's shameful that boris
johnson over the last couple of days
hasn't answered the central
questionnaires yes or no was she at a
party at 10 downing street when everyone
else was in lockdown he could have
cleared this up within the last couple
of days i took the question yesterday
the urgent question he still didn't turn
up to parliament his ministers didn't
turn up to parliament by the unlucky one
that got the short straw and he's still
not answered that question so i think
it's not unsurprising that no one would
turn up today to answer to it because
quite frankly to anyone who lost a loved
one who was not able to visit them and
see them in their dying hours it's
pretty despicable to find that they were
partying at number 10.
he will turn up today because his prime
minister's questions of course if he
doesn't then
that's a whole new uh can of worms isn't
it would you be asking the questions i
don't know yet it depends on case test
results this morning um
i think he's having it this morning i've
been on the media round so i'm not sure
he did test negative yesterday so if he
tested negative this morning then he
should be fine then he can well you know
kissed how much luck so i'm not taking
anything i mean he's had covered what 76
thousand times
he's had a pretty bad run of it yeah we
wish him better and he was negative uh
yesterday so it was so hopefully he'll
be there this afternoon he's had a week
to think about what he's going to ask
the prime minister what do you think his
first question will be i think he'll be
as frustrated as the public are
regarding what the prime minister's done
nobody wants to be in this circumstance
when we're at time of crisis you know
the country are facing a cost of living
crisis there's other things that people
are rightly concerned about at the
moment but quite rightly those that are
still grieving those that remember those
dark days of having those restrictions
will be pretty cheesed off and upset
that they see the prime minister has
actually attended a party in downing
street when he's clearly broken the
rules on the law that's not what we
expect and that's regardless of
political persuasions even conservatives
will say that it's not what you expect
from the prime minister of this country
that was then
some might say this is now um and the
conservatives have managed to steer us
through
a global pandemic well if you look at
our death rates they have been pretty uh
shocking we've seen that the waste in
terms of public procurement contracts
and so therefore whilst there has been
you know the vaccination program that
the nhs works on and our great
scientists in the uk was a great success
and continues to be a success there are
failings that the government have shown
throughout the pandemic but this is the
number one critical one for me is that
the prime minister the allegation is is
that he's lied and he's broke the rules
and broke the law and that is the most
serious allegation you can put to a
prime minister at a time of crisis we
had a yoga of pearl snap poll yesterday
and still 26 percent of people feel that
the prime minister shouldn't resign
that's a reflection on your party as
much as anything
i think you know people are entitled to
their opinions people are concerned at
the moment they just want to see things
improve for their lives and i completely
understand that but many of the public
now i mean it won't come as a shock to
people that i don't think boris johnson
was the right prime minister for this
country but i think the general
population now in the british public
field that they've been lied to deceived
to and are feeling pretty angry and
upset and those that have lost loved
ones and were not able to be there in
those dying hours feel that the prime
minister has really let them down on a
level that they never expected any prime
minister in this country to do yeah you
only have one vote though and the
majority felt that jeremy corbyn was
certainly not the right prime minister
did the party put up the wrong person
against him well you know we in 2019 we
lost the general election and lost it
very badly and we've had to reflect on
that and since i became deputy leader of
the labour party and care became leader
we've been doing a job of making sure
the public can see that we acknowledge
where we were and that we take those
issues forward that's why this week only
yesterday we were in the house of
commons trying to get the government to
relieve the pressures on working
families around the energy crisis that
we face at the moment
so really trying to show the public that
we're on their side and i think that's
starting to cut through and you know we
had to acknowledge that but the actual
you know what people have seen from this
prime minister over the last uh 12
months and certainly in the last couple
of days where he hasn't even had the
decency to answer a very simple question
was you at a party at your flat during
lockdown when people were told not to or
not i think shows the level of the man
really that he hasn't been able to come
forward and say that he's a very busy
man perhaps it was on his other phone he
wasn't very busy yesterday it's an
urgent question he's a parliamentary
didn't know what he was doing on the
20th of may well i think the general
public will make their assumptions i
mean we all saw his media appearance
where he was actually smirking when he
was asked the question i think the
british that's an unfortunate mannerism
that he has when he's under pressure i
don't necessarily i think you know and
i'm not the first i'm certainly not
defending boris johnson but that's some
that's what he does when he's under
pressure
he had the opportunity yesterday through
the urgent question through parliament
to come to the house and to tell the
british public whether he was partying
or not when everybody else was what if
he didn't remember well he should
remember i mean i think he'd find it
pretty hard not to remember whether he
was at a lockdown party or not i
certainly didn't have any lockdown
parties and didn't attend any it doesn't
take me to look at my diary to see
whether or not i was at one or not on
that day i know for a fact i was i mean
look how busy he is well we all were but
i think we all know whether or not we
broke lockdown rules
as far as he is um concerned if he did
are you more concerned that he went to
the party or are you more concerned that
he misled parliament
i think you know the frustration is not
only is it around the fact that he
shouldn't have been breaking the law and
breaking the rules and he should come to
the house and speak to the british
people as quickly as possible about that
but it's the fact that for time and time
again now he said that nothing happened
no rules were broken and the allegation
essentially now is that he was actually
attending this party during lockdown so
it shows that he's not only broke the
rules but he's lied to the british
public and i think that makes his
position completely untenable so you
calling for him to resign i think he i
mean it wouldn't be a surprise that i
think he should go but i think more
crucially now is members of parliament
his conservative mps have to ask
themselves the question is why are we
propping up this man who has lied to the
british public and who has broken the
rules and broke the law
the fact is they are though they're
still supporting him
well we'll see what happens today we'll
see what boris johnson has to say for
himself but anyone who props up a liar
who breaks the law to me is you know
that's a completely unacceptable
position
so so what are you suggesting might
happen today because we have been
speaking to other colleagues other peers
earlier today and they were suggesting
that fewer backbenchers might be behind
him today well i don't know i mean you
could pick up the phone straight away he
could speak to you on your show and you
could clear it off
he could clear it up yeah very quickly
absolutely mr johnson and honestly i can
clear the schedule for you if you're
watching this morning i know you do
watching dining street as you heard from
ms rainer there's room on the sofa for
you exactly as well just come along and
talk to us it's best to come clean it is
and and you know it's the british public
that he needs to come clean to you know
they're the people that have sacrificed
so much our nhs workers are key workers
who have provided care and you know
they've sacrificed not seen their loved
ones and they're they're all upset at
the moment they want to know boris
johnson did you have a party in downing
street when everybody else was in
lockdown yes or no he asked to answer
that question today and if he admits to
it and comes clean and says he's sorry
and he apologizes don't we just move on
then i don't think we can on this to be
honest and i think the last couple of
days have shown that the fact that he's
been lying about it and not telling the
public the truth as well
really undermines his position as prime
minister you can't break it's not what
he did it's about the fact that he
didn't come clean i think it's both i
think it's harmful on both accounts i
think what he did shows that when people
were not seeing their loved ones who
were dying and in critical care they're
really devastated they're still grieving
about that process that they went
through and the prime minister at the
time was partying i mean that in itself
is bad enough but then to try and not
tell the public the truth and come clean
about that i think that just adds insult
to injury but many members of the public
will say
he did he stood by us during um lockdown
he made sure that there was enough money
during the furlough scheme that we could
uh continue on feeding our families and
he's tried to support us as far as
energy prices are concerned let's wait
and see what happens as far as april is
concerned and on balance he is
a good prime minister we've had one of
the highest death tolls you know covid
has been very disastrous for the uk and
you know i pay tribute to those in our
nhs those scientists that helped us with
the vaccination process we haven't had
the inquiry results into what happened
we know billions of pounds were wasted
on ppe contracts and contracts that we
couldn't use and the prime minister now
is the centralized nation as he's lied
to the british public and he's had
parties during the lockdown i think
that's a pretty damning and serious
position for the prime minister to be in
talk to me about the role of the police
well if the law was broken the police
have an obligation to investigate that
and i think they should do that but like
i say this could be cleared up very
quickly by boris johnson yes or no did
you have a party when you shouldn't he
knows that he's the prime minister of
the country but what should the police
be doing they did uh previously i was
saying talking to alistair campbell a
few moments ago
and they did question tony blair under
caution when he was prime minister well
the police have to uphold the law you
know they have an obligation to the
british public you know we complete we
policing this country by consent if the
law was broken they have an obligation
to investigate that but like i say you
know the prime minister you can only
know
they've always been broken if they
investigate and up until now they
haven't yeah and you know i've said that
any findings that sue grey has into her
investigation should be handed over to
the police for them to look at that but
very crucial like i say i think it's not
about what the police have done it's
about boris johnson is the prime
minister of the country he set those
laws in the first place he can very
simply answer the question did you break
the law or not okay we've got a picture
that's just reaching us actually i think
this is the prime minister this morning
in his uh vehicle
there we go i can't really see him can
we but i know that that is the
pm's
car um he is due to be at downing street
shortly and then at the house of commons
by midday today for prime minister's
questions let's see if he attends i'm
sure that he will he is the prime
minister of this country of course
if for how much longer don't know um if
not him then who are you most concerned
about facing opposite the dispatch book
next time your boss gets covered well
we'll have to see what happens today i'm
not concerned about facing any of them
my job is to be the official opposition
and i'll continue to do that and hold
the government to account whoever it is
you know you know his cabinet are just
as responsible as he is and every tory
mp that props him up at the moment are
just as culpable for allowing him to
continue in his role are you confident
that he'll turn up today
he should do but you know you never know
he could have been he could get a
lateral flow test that tests positive or
not but he has the he doesn't have to
attend parliament to tell people whether
or not he attended that party or not he
should have done that immediately he's
had many opportunities over the last
couple of days to do that he's failed to
do it and i think he should come clean
as quickly as possible good to talk to
you this morning thank you very much
indeed for taking the time to join us
thank you